how we doing folks this is a very
special Collider heroes interview encore
and row here as always with Amy Dallen
and we are with Tony Revell Laurie I
don't know thank you guys no more no
more
thank you you of course know him from
many of your favorite movies but
especially as Flash Thompson in
spider-man far from home congratulations
thank you yeah it is out right now and I
know it's been a whole whirlwind of
press and melee of stuff coming together
and now we're here I loved Flash's
evolution from one two to four from
homecoming to here thank you guys got to
play us some subtext yeah we did in the
first movie we really kind of like
wanted to update the bully type of
character and kind of mirror what
bullying is like nowadays which is you
know very much anonymous online word
it's less about the physical stuff and
then on this movie we wanted to explore
a little bit more of flash and his
character arc and story so we kind of
came up with a couple little things and
then at the very end there's one little
moment that I actually came up with the
day of shooting really yeah it was us
arriving all back from from our European
trips and all the families are there
hugging their kids and you know flash is
there and he just walks up to his driver
who has one of those like you know iPads
with his name on it and he's and he just
like he's sad that his family couldn't
make it for him just like I guess that's
what it's like again and if you pay
attention we've retro actively edited a
bunch of that storyline into the movie
would through like the text that that
was first you shot that first shot that
last all right and then in the Edit they
were like we love that so much we have
to put it throughout the entire movie
and we ended up putting like a couple
text messages that he sends that like
Peter sees through certain glasses that
he wears again try not to spoil too much
but yeah that it was it was really fun
to just explore flash and his more
vulnerable side well it's very cool to
hear that this has been a truly
collaborative process kind of working on
this version of the character yeah
always the case or has it grown as you
like going into the second movie you
know it definitely is grown and as it
always will continue to grow when you
work with the director for the first
time you get those first steps and
things like you know move forward and
you know everyone gets comfortable and
this one we were just all kind of saying
and putting in our piece making our our
suggestions to the movie and said why
don't why doesn't my character just fly
out here and then just like you know get
a suit into and we can all just like be
spider-man and fly off and Jacob and I
would have our own adventures as spider
people Marvel Universe on Flash Thompson
in the comics and maybe there's some
spider-man venom hijinks I don't know
I'm not against it so with this flash
you love spider-man and you and there's
a certain element of I've always loved
from the comics the hatred of Peter in
the love of spider-man yeah how do you
see spider-man your Flash well I mean
like having read the comics there's
obviously there and I try to take as
much from the comics obviously I'm not a
physical exact match of Flash Thompson
but then again that character has
evolved from the time I mean like in the
first comic he was a 5-2 red hair short
dude who bullied Peter so it makes no
difference now he's a 6 to jock blond
blue-eyed white guy so it can constantly
be changing and obviously it's really
nice to see the MCU kind of go in a more
diverse step but yeah it was i reaiiy
always loved the duality of loving
spider-man and and we played it in the
first movie and a lot of that kind of
got cut for pacing as you know things
need to and everything so in this movie
we really try to play that up even more
to make sure it ends in the movie and
I'm so glad it did because I think it's
it's it's really hilarious that um he
just loves spider-man so much this is a
person that he sees as a hero a true
person that does inspire him to be
better even though he's such an a-hole
and and he's a terrible human being to
the one person who actually is under
that mask
without knowing it yeah and I think
that's that and then we the more we play
up that it the better it always is and
joking with all the different moments
and everything yeah the moment of
dichotomy in their punch was like what
you're speaking to it's the essence of
the character persisting across
different versions because I values the
wrong things and that's what and you
know in in the comics at least early on
in his kind of bullying moments you
didn't really see what was kind of there
for him in terms of his personality you
you saw some of his backstory of why
afterwards when he graduated high school
when they all graduated high school so
that was like really interesting and
cool to see post-high school Flash
Thompson and taking and incorporating
some of what you can see from those
comics and his the way he looked back on
on that and kind of just taking that and
really running with that now you're one
of the rare crossovers with the
spider-verse in your own way and I
consider dope canon with shameik Moore
who was miles to me from the moment dope
happened before my eyes what's it like
working on something that is also young
and heartfelt and so important dope is
Issy dope and then the scope of
something like a spider-man is it a
different animal beyond those two sets
yeah very much
you know dope we made for I think 1.2
million dollars shooting all around LA
from like you know deep Inglewood Ladera
heights all the way to up in like
panorama city
in that movie that movie was just a
beast to shoot because we shot it in 18
days yeah 18 days we were constantly
just like running against the clock but
we made like what I think is a good
movie and I'm very proud of it so it's
it's a different beast to try and you
know you're you don't never have a
moment's to rest on a film like Spider
Man it's like great we got four hours to
set up for this you know
safety meeting and you know he's gonna
be swinging here this is gonna blow up
this is gonna blow up we have it's gonna
take four hours to set up so everyone
can go take a nap and then on dope it's
like nope we're done you're moving on to
the next all right now it's here there
okay even though you have not in the
scene we need you to be ready for that
same so you got to go change get this
and you're constantly going constantly
like figuring it out and it's really
nice to do that cuz you're constantly
just like in motion everyone feels like
they're working towards one project that
is and and in this movie as well but it
you know you have a little bit more
leeway flexing different muscles flexing
different muscles and yeah I mean
speaking to shamekh and and Keirsey you
also with the incredible us three both
went on to do comic book movies right
after yeah shamekh with with
spider-verse me with spider-man and
accuracy with the flash movie yeah and
the DC Universe but yeah it was really
fun we all kind of like joke about it
it's like all right it's like obviously
we did that movie of course like all of
us were gonna be in some sort of comic
we'll come back for the sequel and make
inside jokes about you know DC and
Marvel it'll be about mm since the 90s
it's a lot of mm Melly very popular no
Jake Shauna Paul do the Sean Paul love
is strong can you speak to making far
from home speaking of the inside jokes
coming out just for us watching that
process the camaraderie that built up
among this man
no he's great um I mean it was a lot of
fun obviously seeing Tom's and daya
Jacob and Anne gallery again were was
great you know and Gary was 15 when we
shot the first movie and she think gee I
think she turned 18
right as we wrap this one uh and it was
it was great like you know we were all
just hanging out and joining the new
cast members from like you know Remy he
and Zack Barak we're all just hanging
out and having fun and and Jacob Remy
and I stayed in a little apartment
complex that we were constantly just be
hanging out of each other
you know cooked for each other go to a
bar this that and Zack was a block away
so he would constantly be joining us and
there's just we just had a lot of fun on
set and when all of us were on set
together it was just a riot they had to
keep telling us to keep quiet and
everything which was terrible but yeah
it was it was a lot of fun shooting with
these guys and you know hopefully uh
we'll be back for another one yeah
there'll be many more to come
now the snap being what it was it was
really cool to experience the the Marvel
Universe with such a change from the
comics with you as a comic fan when you
first found out the scope of what they
were doing we won't we won't touch on
spoilers for the future we can talk
about endgame it's been out a while the
moment you found out about the end game
snaps and I'm like that ramifications I
knew that right as infinity war was
maybe a month in theaters we started
doing this and I had to read the script
and this spoiled end game for me because
obviously we so we had to we had to
figure out and then when we got to
London
they sat us down and told us who's gone
what's happening what on earth we need
to know for our you know yeah so I was
like just I mean like it's that but it's
also like no I don't get to enjoy the
movie
and I went to the endgame premiere and
that was awesome and it was so much fun
but it was it was like and here it comes
that was cut out with my friend and he
he was he was like you gotta write down
in an envelope and I want to know if you
actually really know everything that
happened he put it in his pocket when he
when we were he was done he opened it up
and he was like yeah you do everything
but I know he did actually he was like
what does it actually take place as it
is and it's like yeah I know you don't
want me the thing is people ask me for
spoilers they don't want the spoilers
they want me to toy with that yes the
tease that's what people want were the
note against a very Flash Thompson mood
be like you better tell me you're on the
other end of a flat I'll check later
exactly what it is but no it was it was
it was it was cool to know you know it
was like it was definitely fun to be and
funny enough at the end game premiere I
saw Kevin Feige on the carpet and he was
like yeah you know more than actually
some of these other people some people
don't know who if they're dead or not
you do oh my god I felt like I had all
the power of like I know just as much as
he does was it at all tempting to go
ruin it for someone no no no I would
feel terrible to do that if I was like
you know if I just would I mean like
obviously I'm pretty sure down he knew
he went but like if I went up to
Scarlett Johansson I'm like you die so
well in this movie waiting seems
actually a funeral yeah exactly
yeah I know you've got you've been
sitting with us for a little while
but we haven't had a chance to talk this
through with you before and speaking to
the fandom side and what you love have
you is a long-term connection with
comics do you have a moment that you
fell in love or has it been a joy of
discovering it as you go yeah it's been
a bit of all of those things
I am I
I grew grew up with the comics I I
didn't have I saw the first spider-man
movie before I read a comic and I loved
it I thought like wow this is a movie
made for kids and adults but also like
it's for me
this feels for me and I like you know
was pumped to see the entirety of it
like the next movie that I thought was
gonna come out and the x-men and all
these kind of series and then as I got a
little bit older I started buying more
comics and once I you know came into
some of some money for my work in acting
I kept buying more comics and more
comics and uh and it was all growing
comics it was growing and it just grew
it grew and then you know around 14
there was a bit of time where I kind of
like dropped it off a little bit and the
crest hadn't really come where you know
geekdom and nerdom was like at its peak
yeah so you know you drop it you start
doing other things you get busy you grow
up and then and then it all crusted back
up again and then around 18 you know I
was back at it again maybe small you
know reading Wikipedia pages of like
panels cuz I could I think is I felt so
overwhelmed because now I'd missed so
much that I was like where I where do I
start what do I buy sure do I need to
know the backstory of all you know it is
very daunting so I just went on
Wikipedia and online and just kept
reading every single like synopsis for
things which is not a great way to read
common handbooks just browsing so tell
me all of the stories until I get read
and then I'm in and so then yeah and
then like you know obviously once I got
spider-man they just kept sending me
comics and comics I was like yeah great
and I'm back in the game again it took
four years off that was a comic snapping
of sorts and you got back in through PD
I learned what the world was it sounds
Canon yeah right there was a five-year
break I blink that I missed it yeah I
got a no Wes Anderson grand Budapest we
talked about you getting you getting
started man he is like it's it's goddamn
art it's so magical thank you what was
it like working on a movie that looks
like a comic you know you know it was
I've never thought of his looking at
wood the way we always phrased it was it
looked like every frame you could pause
and it's a painting it's a photo that
you would hang on your wall and it was
it was difficult you know there was
there was a lot of things and a lot of
preparation and moments that needed to
go into it that I wasn't a part of but
you know when I came into it I had to be
prepared since I was basically the only
person without an Oscar nomination and
you know Wes is a very you know quick
and and and you know he shoots very
quickly and he gives you a lot of
directions very quickly and you gotta
just like keep it all in your brain and
it's staying here do this move here do
this grab your line say that line he
look at him do this grab the painting
theorist move there grab there put there
stand there turn there there cool got it
cool great and you know I'd miss maybe
one and then he was like no worries all
good just go again we go again and then
I'd nail it and we would do about 40
takes for every shot but it's so quick
he doesn't he doesn't ever cut he
doesn't let people come in and less
things need to be like reset for safety
or for props or something he'll just be
like great and go again great and go
again great here's what needs to be done
great go again great so it's like we get
10 takes in five minutes and it's just
like continuously going that's
incredible awesome yeah I feel like the
kind of training you get from that
probably carries forward nicely too yeah
you know I was talking about it recently
but but the way West shoots is way more
like an indie movie then it shoots like
a spider
movie because he's very much about that
indie kind of filmmaking
where everyone's like quick you know
even though it's it's it's comfortable
indie making is what I'd like crafty
still there everyone eats very well
timing is like their no-one's Russian
but also people are like working which
is great it's a great energy to have
what kind of challenges would you like
to take on next since you've already
done three completely different types of
film there's three different um you know
I'd love to be in something dramatic or
epic or you know something like like a
Lawrence of Arabia hmm I would love to
be in a Lawrence of Arabia type like The
Alchemist if they ever make that movie
or or like I love rom-coms
I do like unabashedly love rom-com so I
would love to be a lead in a rom-com
Lawrence of Arabia rom-coms you I got an
O in universe
how did Flash Thompson start up the
flash mob yes Howdy's by buying a lot of
bots I don't know what in the movie it
shows how many followers I have and I
don't remember what the number actually
was but John and I were saying like all
of these guys are fake right I really
like both said like he shouldn't
actually like he is like maybe if he has
a hundred thousand maybe ten thousand or
actual like people who follow and and
like common baby life in whatever but
it's not like yes a lot but most of that
is BOTS basic and that's so on brand I
love that answer so much that days yeah
I'd like now my next viewing has an
entire new perspective okay and
obviously not spoilers because they
couldn't tell us anyway but since we do
all love the tease what would you want
for Flash's future we were talking about
Flash post-grad
in the compost yeah um you know I think
flash has a rich history in many
different comics with different things I
would love to see him in a kind of
friendship role with Peter because
there's there's precedent in the comics
that he was Peters best man at his
wedding which is so surprising when I
found that out cuz I was like oh I guess
so
so you know seeing them become more
friendly to each other it would be fun I
would love to see him and take flash you
know out of the kind of states and into
a army setting where you know he has
been and you know the venom stuff's
there but I think the real kind of heart
and meat of Flash's character is really
that kind of beginning bit with having
is like you know friendship with Peter
and and going and joining the army and I
think that would be I think that would
be great
last question for you go for it for you
is Tony any comic or comic movie or
property you'd recommend for someone
that has never heard of a comic
oh the gateway drug the weed you know I
would start with like a complete story
so that way at least you can get
something like thick and read through it
and maybe I would go that's a tough one
you know what I mean I'm gonna go you
know the amazing spider-man story like
Volume one yeah yeah dico and way back
in the day yeah that was really fun to
read and flash is great in that like I
really enjoy the old flat and I like the
evolution of Flash I think I think the
strength of spider-man is how great his
rogues gallery is and how great his
supporting characters are absolutely his
family and friends are so vital and I
love the college era where Mary Jane
talks I guess 70s like what like the
dialogue that comes out of her like this
hip cat and they're like so much fun in
that era of that early so I agree so
yeah I mean I think it's it's really fun
and
we'll have fun oh you know he's waving
understand I'm just saying you guys have
like a bunch of watch your language
things I think you should just put up
pictures of Captain America going one
language we should actually for this so
on brains Chris we'd need a photo sign
with us congratulations on the film
thank you very very much
you did a wonderful interview with Teen
Vogue where you talked about what it
meant to you to change just by being in
these films no absolutely yeah
I had a great time sorry I can see him
going like oh man another three minutes
but no it was it was a great article if
more people want to read it it's it's
still up on the website I'm sure maybe a
link will be put up or something I don't
know but either way it was it was a it
was great you know and just learning how
toxic masculinity is in different eras
and how you can break it and not even
just break it but just kind of lessen it
change what's possible thank you so much
always love sake man I'm glad this all
worked out my graduations on flashman
they cling and every you ready guys five
more minutes
[Laughter]